das
wird
und damit meine lieben freunde darf ich
euch heute recht herzlich willkommen
heißen zu einer neuen reaction auf das
video das verrückte leben eines
16-jährigen internet millionärs von
wissenswert 16 jahren ein alter in dem
die meisten noch die schulbank drücken
nicht mal mehr auto fahren dürfen und
oft mehr interesse an partys medien und
ihren gleichaltrigen haben als daran zu
lernen zu arbeiten oder etwas für ihre
zukunft zu tun mit 16
hab ich
gerade erst gelernt wie es ist sich
selbst den arsch abzuwischen auch wenn
er eine ausnahme ist gibt es auch 16
jährige wie den australier ben pasternak
mit gerade einmal 16 jahren schaffte es
pasternak nämlich durch einige kluge
online-business es richtig reich zu
werden und offiziell als millionär
eingestuft zu werden mein online
business ist mein youtube kanal
ja ist nicht mein euro wert inzwischen
besitzt er laut einigen finanzmagazin
sogar ein privatvermögen von ganzen
reigen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich hab nicht mal die ersten beiden
ziffern da auf dem konto ben pasternak
wurde kurz vor der jahrtausendwende am 6
september 1999 in sydney geboren müssen
wir überlegen
mehrfacher millionär
und dann gibt es uns hier
wir gucken uns so was an seinen
großvater war in australien ein
wohlhabender unternehmer der ein
vermögen von ca 300 millionen dollar hat
ja gut ich meine dann hast es ja auch
irgendwie schon mitbekommen sonne schon
als junge im alter von sechs jahren
begann sich ben dann für technik zu
interessieren
er war fasziniert von modernen
technologien und auch von der welt des
internets so gründete er bereits mit
zehn jahren einen eigenen youtube kanal
auf dem er bereits kurz nach der
veröffentlichung neuer smartphones und
anderer geräte video reviews zu den
produkten machte ok krass
habe mir meinen youtube-kanal glaube ich
mit vierzehn gemacht
das falsch
in den folgenden jahren fing werden dann
an sich mit dem programmieren und mit
software auseinander zu setzen und
lernte so auch die grundlagen von app
entwicklung und webdesign
ich kann das nicht als er 14 war kam er
dann auf eine erste geniale idee ok aus
langeweile entwickelte er im
schulunterricht das einfache aber
geniale handyspiel impossible rasch
listen eis
mit dem dt
sid die frage wer hat hier von wem
geklaut nach dem besten weg das game
dann im app store veröffentlicht
schafft er die app ist innerhalb
kürzester zeit bis auf platz 16 der
weltweit am meisten gedownloadet apps
nur meine app war auf platz eins durch
diesen erfolg erlangte benbennek dann
erstmals einige aufmerksamkeit in der
tech-branche
so knüpft der unter anderem kontakt zu
chris mit einem filmemacher der auch in
der tech industrie sich machst du also
nicht kennen würde so boten sowohl
facebook als auch google pasternak im
januar 2015 als er gerade einmal 15
jahre alt war
praktiker an die ben jedoch dankend
ablehnte wenn google
und facebook die in angebot machen für
einen job mit 15 jahren
ja ich war bei einer kleinen
elektrofirma bielefeld er wollte die
schule abbrechen um seine gesamte zeit
in seine neueste app idee zu stecken und
blog
wenn's idee hinter flock war es ein
soziales netzwerk zu gründen welches den
obersten zweck hatte dass man dort
sachen an seine freunde verkaufen konnte
quasi wie ein online trödelmarkt der
allerdings sicherer ist als ebay da man
dort nur innerhalb des eigenen
freundeskreises kaufen und verkaufen
kann eigentlich richtig nahe
ich habe gerade so viele sachen die ich
irgendwie loswerden will seinen alten
laptop alte bildschirme kameras und ich
weiß einfach nicht wie
ich konnte ich konnte gewünscht machen
wir den bock gehabt trotz dieser
genialen idee erlaubten ihm seine eltern
jedoch nicht die schule abzubrechen
stattdessen stellte bens mutter ihm eine
bedingung
er dürfe nur die schule abbrechen wenn
er es schaffen würde ausreichend
risikokapital für seine idee
aufzutreiben
es hätte ich nicht gemacht als
elternteil
immer
egal was ist immer
vernünftigen abschluss machen die idee
kann noch so gut sein es kann immer
schief gehen oder das sind nichts in der
tasche an seinem letzten schultag lebte
er auf die innenseite seines schließfach
es in der schule ein post-it mit der
aufschrift you suck
es ist natürlich eine super motivation
wenn er auf seiner suche nach investoren
also nicht erfolgreich sein würde würde
er am ersten schultag wiederkommen
müssen und zu recht diese unschöne
botschaft lesen ach so
das ist gut meine motivation bestand aus
chocobos nachdem ihm das geld zugesagt
wurde brach wenn also die schule ab und
entschied sich kurzerhand im alter von
15 jahren in die usa auszuwandern
das hatte ich gar nicht auf dem schirm
dass der 15 jahre alt ist
zwar überlegen
mit 15 jahren bin ich beim fußball bei
einer flanke gegen den pfosten
gesprungen und in der stadt die niemals
schläft brauchte er mit seinem team dann
gerade mal ein jahr um flock
fertigzustellen so dass er mit flock im
april 2016 damals im alter von 16 jahren
bereits eine zweite app launcher zum
glück von ben und seinen investoren war
auch block wieder ein voller erfolg
alter aber bei der app hätte ich sie
dann auch sagen können
wer es nicht denn hatte mit 16 jahren
also schon so ziemlich alles erreicht
dennoch widmete er sich dann nach dem
launch von flock unverzüglich dem
nächsten projekt richtig so dicker
richtig so weitermachen bruder hassel
patzen patzen
v
ich habe übrigens lampen reparierten
auch so ein kleiner internet
typ
öffentlich der im november des gleichen
jahres seine nächste apple monkey monkey
war eine videochat bei der man
automatisch mit wildfremden menschen
verbunden wurde
die ähnliche interessen teilen wie man
selbst also quasi so ohm tv
nur auf dem handy auch monkey wurde wie
zu erwarten ein totaler erfolg krank
nebenplatz 1 in den app trend rang
schafften die app ist bis zum heutigen
tage mehr als 20 milliarden video
konversation zu vermitteln und wurde im
jahr 2017 von einer tech firma namens
honor für eine vermutlich siebenstellige
summe erworben
[Applaus]
wie kann denn alles was er macht alles
was er berührt und anfasst zu gold
werden
wenn einer ein euro stücke anfangs
kommen dann 500 scheine raus mit einem
partner gründete er die firma max das
produkt dieser firma sind veganer
chicken nuggets die mit einer speziellen
technologie aus erbsen protein
hergestellt werden wie er
dieser typ ist ja unfassbar auch wenn
max noch mitten in der entwicklung ist
und somit noch kein produkt
veröffentlicht werden konnte sieht das
projekt bereits vielversprechend aus der
kanadische lebensmittelkonzern mccain
foods investierte beispielsweise 7
millionen dollar in das projekt von
[Applaus]
was
bisher war mein absolutes vorbild was
rasseln und so angeht immer casey
leistet
aber wenn du bis auf guten weg auch
anzukommen egal wie alt man ist wenn man
sich sowas anguckt dass in jedem
menschen muss einfach dieses um
im gehirn passieren von wegen
ich packe jetzt mein handy weg gaben
hier nicht rum auf social media sondern
mache was ich will auch was machen die
welt verändern geldverdienen alles um
mich motiviert zu was so krank er
besitzt nur wenige möbel und schlief
während er an seinem blog arbeitete
sogar nur auf einer matratze
grund dafür ist eine weitere seiner
verrückten motivationsstrategien er
wollte sich erst ein richtiges bett
kaufen wenn er flog erfolgreich
gelauncht hatte alter ich weiß ja bei
mir war es so als ich damals meine
wohnungen hatte und so ich habe mir die
ganze zeit nichts von meinem ganzen
youtuber geld gekauft keine
markenklamotten kein irgendwie teures
auto keinen schmuck keine accessoires
gar nichts in einzige investitionsidee
die ich hatte mein einziger wunsch bei
ihnen wenn mal eine wohnung zu kaufen
damit ich dieses dach über dem kopf auf
jeden fall schonmal safe habe dass ich
das gekauft habe dass ich keine miete
mehr zahlen muss und erst als ich die
wohnung damals in köln gekauft haben
fünf jahren oder so erst dann gesagt so
jetzt kann ich mir so ein bisschen mal
was gönnen
ich glaube er hatte dann sehr ähnlicher
ansicht seine tage verbringt er nämlich
ausschließlich mit seinen business
projekten und ist dabei fast immer zwölf
stunden am tag beruflich außer haus und
selbst in seinen eigenen vier wänden
meistens mit seinen projekten
beschäftigt er hat einfach seine ganzen
küchen wände voll geschrieben seine
schranktüren alter überall wenn da
jemand normales reinkommen würde der
bedenken der typ ist verrückt und
schizophrenen beim frühstück versucht er
das essen sogar noch radikaler zu
umgehen und ernährt sich so meistens von
frühstücks drinks die mit sämtlichen
nährstoffen angereichert sind und somit
eine vollwertige mahlzeit ersetzen
können als sich im dezember hier auf
youtube extrem durchgezogen habe und
insgesamt 60 videos hochgeladen habe auf
mein haupt und zwei kanal da habe ich
mir extra von seinem unternehmen
das hat echt richtig scheiße geschmeckt
so ein geparktes essen bestellt was ich
dann einfach in die mikrowelle bauern ab
da ich bin auch morgens aufgestanden
direkt am pc der dinge in die mikrowelle
gearbeitet dann habe ich das gegessen
und es war auch eine vollwertige meist
aber das ist natürlich kein leben das
kann man mal machen aber das ist echt
ich empfehlenswert auf eine längere
dauer in interviews gibt sich bin
nämlich nie besonders stolz sondern eher
unbeeindruckt von seinem eigenen erfolg
der jäger so ein absoluter ihren mann
es ist so irre
drei jahre jünger als ich
und hat so viel mehr erreicht sein
mindset ist so viel weiter der hat
mehrere businesses
und ich
doch an der stelle wird der heutige
jetzt auch beenden meine lieben freunde
ein riesiges riesiges dankeschön geht
raus an wissenswert dass sich auf dieses
video hier reagieren durfte mir hat es
extrem viel weitergeholfen schreibt bei
uns in die kommentare was ihr bisher in
eurem leben so erreicht habt
ich habe etwas gegessen und diese lampe
repariert
[Musik]